foreign
and sincere welcome to Northeast
Derbyshire District Council Offices here
today for This truly momentous occasion
proclamation of his majesty King Charles
III
those who don't know me I'm Lee hicking
I'm the managing director here at
Northeast Yorkshire District Council and
I'm joined at the podium today by the
chair of the council councilor Diana
ruff
the leader of the council councilor Alex
Dale and representing his Majesty's
constabulary will inspector John true
first of all if I could please ask
everyone
to join me in a minute's silence Mark
the sad passing of our late Queen
thank you very much
I now have great pleasure in handing
over to you the chair of the council
councilor Diana Ross who will now
introduce and read the proclamation Casa
Diana Ross
thank you we'd like to take a seat
we come together this afternoon
following the passing of our late
Sovereign Queen Elizabeth II
our sadness at this time is shared by
people across the globe
as we recommend for sorry as we remember
with affection and gratitude the
lifetime of service given by our longest
reigning monarch
but the basis on which our monarchy is
built has ensured that through the
centuries the crown has passed in an
unbroken line of succession
today's ceremony marks the formal
proclamation to the people of Northeast
derbyshire's District of the beginning
of our new King's reign
yesterday the Ascension Council met at
St James's Palace to Proclaim our new
sovereign
the flights which have flown at half
Mars since the Queen's death were raised
to their full height to Mark the start
of his Majesty's reign
the Ascension Council also made an order
requiring the high sheriffs to cause the
proclamation to be read in the areas of
their jurisdiction
the high Sheriff of Derbyshire
discharged that Duty earlier today
and now with my humble Duty I bring the
words of the proclamation to the
citizens of Northeast District
Derbyshire
the proclamation of the new Sovereign is
a very old tradition which can be
treated and traced back to many
centuries
the ceremony does not create a new king
it is simply an announcement of this
session which took place immediately on
the death of the reigning monarch
in an age where Modern methods of
communication conveys news around the
globe in an instant the proclamation is
no longer the means by which people
learn for the first time that they have
a new monarch
today however is one of the first
occasions when communities have an
opportunity to come together and reflect
on the moment in our nation's history
when the reign of our longest serving
Monarch came to an end and a new
Sovereign succeeded
ladies and gentlemen will you please
stand whilst I read the proclamation
the proclamation
whereas it has pleased almighty God to
call to his Mercy our late Sovereign
Lady Queen Elizabeth II but blessed and
Glory
by whose deceased the crown of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland is solely and
rightfully come to
it off the George
we therefore the Lord's spiritual and
Temple of Israel and members of the
House of Commons together with other
members for the late Majesty's privy
Council and representatives of the realm
and territories vorderman and citizens
of London and others do now hereby with
one voice and consent of turn and talked
publish and complain that the Prince
Charles did it Arthur George Is Now by
The Death of our late Sovereign of happy
memory become our only lawful and
rightly these Lord Charles III
by the grace of God of United Kingdom of
Great Britain and Northern Ireland and
his other Realms and territories
King head of the Commonwealth defender
of the faith to whom we do acknowledge
all faith and obedience with humble
affection
the cinching God by whom kings and
queens do Reign to bless His Majesty
with long and happy years to Reign Over
Us
given at St James Palace this 10th day
of September in the year of Our Lord
2022.
God save the key
ladies and gentlemen if you'd like to
join me in three cheers for his majesty
the king if hip hooray hip hip
ladies and gentlemen there will be one
verse for the national anthem which I
hope you will all join in
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
this brings the proclamation ceremony to
an end
we will now reset the flag at half mast
once again to continue to Mark the
passing of our lead monitor
please feel free to join us for light
Refreshments in the council chamber
on behalf of Northeast Derbyshire
District Council I thank you all
sincerely for your attendance at this
Monument monumentous occasion today and
wish you all a safe journey home thank
you